so by now most everybody knows that
chadwick boseman died
at 43 years old and he died of cancer
um you know i can only really speak
about this from a comic book fans
perspective you know obviously i don't
know chadwick boseman on a personal
level i never did i never met him i
always thought it'd be kind of cool to
meet the guy who played black panther
but i think i can speak for especially
the black community and comic book fans
that the loss of chadwick boseman is big
it's a big loss
in a lot of ways uh just from the black
american
you know black american perspective you
know i always saw chadwick boseman
as part of the trinity of young black
actors in hollywood
right john david washington michael b
jordan chadwick boseman
the three most talented young black
actors in hollywood
right they are wildly capable in terms
of their abilities you know
the kind of passion and the kind of
talent they brought to the movies
that they made was incredible but from a
comic book fans perspective
the loss of chadwick boseman is huge
because he played black panther
right you know a little bit of history
here for the black population in america
comic books were always a bit of a rough
patch back in the 40s i think it was
you had a line of comics uh really just
like a singular comic called all negro
comics it was a one shot right and it
was just
circulated about the black community
right you didn't really really see it
anywhere else
um in the mid 1950s a guy by the name of
don rico
uh wrote a very short series called
jungle tales which focus on an african
king named
watu i think it was and then you go into
the 1960s right the 1960s gave us things
like sam wilson right 1969 it gave us
uh black panther's first appearance in
fantastic four number 52
in 1966 right you got luke cage in in
the 1970s you saw black characters
appearing
more and more but in comparison to
people like sam wilson in comparison to
people like luke cage
black panther was he stood alone right
he was a wholly different beast
because with sam wilson he was a
sidekick to captain america with luke
cage he was uh
an aspect of the black exploitation
genre right so he was your
stereotypical black gangster from the
ghetto is basically what he was um
with black panther it was it was a whole
different beast right because when he
was introduced in the old fantastic four
comics by stan lee and jack kirby
he wasn't introduced as some kind of
black gangster
right he wasn't introduced like a
stereotype or sidekick he was introduced
as the king of an african kingdom he was
a king of the most
technologically advanced kingdom in the
entirety of the world right the way his
country was depicted back in those old
fantastic four comics and even now
the way it's depicted it would take the
rest of the world 100 years to catch up
and assuming that it did wakanda would
be 100 years beyond that point right so
humanity
would never catch up with wakanda one of
the most notable things of black panther
as he was the first major or he was the
first black super or black character
to have his own publication in a major
publication right dell comics
had black bass uh black superheroes who
had their own comics despite being
short-lived
but in terms of the big two right marvel
and dc black panther was the first one
right he appeared in jungle a jungle
action it was written by don mcgregor
and and this introduced the the villain
eric killmonger who's probably one of
the most interesting villains
in in the history of comics because when
you look at him
he was part and parcel to the black
panther mythos if the mindset of marvel
at the time was
let's introduce a black character who's
not some stereotype but instead
pays homage to the history of blacks in
the world right like
africa african kings right we pay homage
to all that we also basically introduce
him as a guy who's wildly intelligent
and then we in turn create a villain to
face off against him let's do the same
thing and so eric killmonger
was a wildly intelligent guy right he
wasn't just your run-of-the-mill villain
who ran up on wakanda one day beat black
panther and then took over no
he had a he had a blood feud but he had
a grudge against wakanda there was
history there there was build up there
more so than that unlike the movie and
the comic books eric killmonger didn't
be black panther
when t'challa was normal no no he beat
black panther
despite the black panther's powers that
was one of the things that made eric
killmonger so wildly capable imagine
that up in the movie
uh michael b jordan's character had
defeated t'challa despite all of his
powers
that's what made eric killmonger so cool
the fact that he had degrees from like
mit and different things like that he
was just
a super intelligent guy but the long and
short of this is that when it comes to
the black panther mythos in in marvel
comics
for a lot of black americans it's
incredibly important
there's a lot of incredibly important
history there because inside the comic
you know yeah black panther who's the
king of a nation he's got a rich culture
and an even richer history
and for a lot of black americans who
over the years had seen what seemed to
be
the proud culture of of african society
kind of being removed from american
society they were losing touch with
their roots
and being able to see that kind of
history you know brought back
and reinstated among the black of the
black population
was incredibly important it was
incredibly huge right when marvel
announced
a black panther film now you guys all
remember that phase three video that was
made that somebody recorded it
and it was the biggest thing ever right
you know yeah kevin feige up there on
stage and saying hey guys let's talk
about phase three
there you go phase four whatever it is
you know let's talk about the new movies
that are that are gonna be coming out
where you got carol danvers we get this
we get that
so on and so forth and they announced
black panther so here
we have three existing franchise
characters
one new one so i think it's time on
november 3rd 2017
to announce a new one you guys want to
see a new character for the first time
okay here he is
and the top plum came off that place it
was nuts right people were going crazy
it was like oh my god black panther
you know and so from there the pressure
was on because now you're talking about
the marvel cinematic universe
introducing what is probably the single
most important black character
in the history of marvel comics which
hits in a couple different ways one it
hits the black community
and it hits comic book fans as comic
book fans we are not a forgiving breed
of people
if you take a character that we love and
you put them in a movie and you screw it
up
we'll never let you live it down right
we will we will never
go see that version of that character
again and we'll we'll scream on social
media and the whole nine yards but you
will know it's like when a woman gets a
pair of pants that have pockets right
like
don't make sure you know right that's
just that's kind of how it is and so
you know when when when we saw his
character introduced
in in civil war that was a taste you
know to me it was a sampling right we
just got to cut to see like what black
panther would look like
in action and it was cool for what it
was my mind was on the movie
right what's wakanda going to look like
what's the culture going to look like
what's the dora malachi
going to look like what are all these
things going to look like
in movie four right so we finally get
around to the release of the film we get
around to opening night
on black panther and and i was so
excited
i was so hyped right i was just like oh
my god this is gonna be amazing like
like i have no idea what it's gonna be
like
this movie can either do really well or
it's going to bomb
it's not going to be an in-between film
it's not going to be one that just
did pretty decent like it's it's going
to do great or terrible right
there's not going to be an in-between
here get in there
sit down in my seat two and a half hours
later i come out
it was amazing it was amazing it was an
adventure the storytelling
the the depth of the characters the
depiction of eric killmonger by michael
b jordan
and and chadwick boseman's portrayal of
t'challa
the accent the whole nine yards and i
understand that he's playing a character
that was written for him on a screenplay
but at the end of the day it really kind
of does come down to that actor's
interpretation of the character
those are words on a page right and
that's the
biggest issue that i have to imagine
chadwick boseman had to contend with
in playing the role of black panther
unlike his biopic where he was playing
james brown
he's got interviews and concerts to
reference he can pick up on those
mannerisms
the way in which he dances he can talk
to people who knew
james brown when he was alive there's a
lot of experience he can gain there with
black panther
he's a character who's the you know the
method in which he speaks
the way that he looks how he moves
changes from one comic volume to the
next and it changes
from one writer to the next no one
writer's depiction of black panther is
the same as another
it is in so far as general themes the
king of wakanda
protecting his people above all else
different things like that but how he
talks how he carries himself
it changes it fluctuates there's no
universal standard by which
chadwick boseman could sit down and
analyze the character he just kind of
had to read over whatever comics were
presented to him
by whoever presented those comics and
then try to adapt the character as best
he could
and he did it in spectacular fashion
he did it in incredible fashion it was
it was incredible to see and that in and
of itself is the tragedy of all this
right chadwick boseman was one of the
single most
talented actors that hollywood had to
offer and he was a proud member of the
black community it was so great to be a
part of black community and to see him
out there like that
portraying these landmark characters
right
the five bloods to show his character in
that movie was incredible
to see him play in the biopic of james
brown and to portray the history of that
character
was incredible and to see him play black
panther from a comic book fans
perspective
was incredible and i firmly believe
that hollywood is diminished without
chadwick boseman
because that's the kind of talent he
brought to the films that he made
and it's so tragic to see such an
incredible talent
to see that end in such a terrible way
to see it end at the hands of cancer
because the guy was at his prime
the guy had nowhere to go but up right i
mean it was
it's awful to see it really is and from
a comic book fans perspective which
again is the only
real insight i can offer here uh but
from a comic book fans perspective
it it is a massive loss because from now
until forevermore no matter who it is
that plays black panther it will not be
chadwick boseman
it will not be him and that's gonna suck
anytime i sit down and watch the
original black panther film it's gonna
be sad
because he'll never be able to he'll
never play that character again we'll
never
see him play that character in that way
to make that character his own because
you know it's i have a hard time
believing anybody is going to be able to
live up to that
and that's the pressure for all the
other actors out there a guy who's so
ridiculously talented
that it's scary played one of the most
iconic
black superheroes the most iconic black
superhero in the history of comic books
and passed on good luck to whoever is
going to take over that role next
you've got big shoes to fill but in the
moment i want to focus on
chadwick boseman i just i just want to
say you know if
i doubt the members of chadwick wilson's
family are ever going to see this
i doubt that's ever going to happen uh
but if they happen to
i don't know you i've never met you i
never met chadwick boseman
never talked to him once in my life i
would love to have been able to do that
but never talk to him once but
understand
his the the loss of him despite not
knowing him on a personal level
even if only knowing him from what i saw
in a movie hits
hard because he was so
talented so with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
and i will catch you all later peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you